you know are tough to handle right now
is just the increased demand like i
mentioned before
everyone wants an error in boxing
they're building now from
uh your retirement homes and seniors
that can't afford to
you know risk their lives to go return a
stock at the local walmart at the local
target to higher end property manager
groups that are looking to offer this
amenity
towards showing their customers and
their tenants that they are making an
increased effort towards being able to
protect the safety and everything in
light of the pandemic so we're really
excited about the future
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
and is sponsored by leumitech hippo
insurance touring
upwards labs and hillel at stanford
returning products
sucks but thankfully we have flindall to
help solve it
meet ugochi oho the ceo of flindle a
reverse logistics and proptech startup
focused on automating commerce returns
they make returning anything
ridiculously easy for consumers of
retail businesses and viable for
retailers
they make it possible for consumers of
retail stores to drop off their returns
from the comfort of their homes
without risking the exposure and
inconvenience of venturing outdoors
gochi oh how are you i'm good how are
you
i'm doing just fine i'm doing very very
well now that we're having this
conversation
i'm excited to learn all about your
journey all about flendel
your your experience and your passion
not for logistics but your passion for
solving puzzles
and so i'm excited to get to know you a
little bit better over these 20 minutes
you know just to get us started and tell
me a little bit about what you're doing
with flendel and and once you do
to set up the stage i want to go back
and hear about the journey of of
creating flindle because that's always
the most interesting piece of an
entrepreneur's journey
for sure i mean fundal we are a reverse
logistics company focused
on automating commerce returns that just
means that we make returning anything
super super easy
uh so what the vision is for flindle is
that uh you'll never have to go to the
store or to the post office to drop off
any type of return whether it's from
a brick and mortar store like a walmart
or target or from an online store
um powered by proper buys you'll be able
to do that right in the lobby of your
apartment building your office building
or your condo building and get your
refund within a 24-hour time frame
i love that i have to say that i still
haven't until today and my girlfriend
will kill me if she hears this
i still have a pair of shoes that i've
been meaning to return online
and they're sitting in the back of my
car because just you know going
taking that trip you know in a covet
obviously it's harder but taking that
trip any time you know the post office
or dropping off at a certain piece
it just never seems to fit in the hours
of the day and you just keep delaying it
delaying it
and it just doesn't happen so i'm
waiting to be a customer
of flundle so please just sign me up
already and but you know
now going a little bit backwards so tell
me a little bit about your upbringing
and how you get
to become a you know an early stage
entrepreneur what led you to that route
for sure um well growing up
i've always been like i mentioned
earlier when speaking with you i've
always been into solving uh
puzzles so i'm type of person that
if i am solving one of those like three
thousand uh piece
uh puzzles and there's a movement thing
i'll actually go to the store
and get another box and then find that
one piece to be
i mean it was huge it was secrecy of
mine but then at the end of the day it
ended up paying off so
as a kid i was always into like
presenting and you know i
would go to meetings with my dad and
stuff like that growing up and
it i hated it as a kid because who wants
to go into an adult meeting but
it ended up paying off um you know
growing up and
basically what happened that triggered
flindle was that
i was i purchased an item a few years
ago
um off of a website um which was like
the store was based somewhere in
california and at the time i was in
toronto
um for something and the it was a pair
of sunglasses
the sunglasses were 100 i was totally
fine with paying that the shipping cost
was 150
and on top of that it would take like
two weeks for it to be able to get to my
house
and i became the most annoying person to
be around for about six months i would
tell people
you know what's really annoying shipping
and here's why and
at the time i love that the idea was to
uh the idea was to start like a
localized
um aliexpress amazon style thing but for
everybody else
and what we realized at the time i was
super lucky that i had friends that had
online commerce stores that were like
doing crazy numbers and i asked them
like hey um before i commit to this idea
is your problem
fulfillment like is getting an item from
like your warehouse to where the
customer is your issue
and they said no and i said you're lying
i don't want to hear it
that's a lie of course um
so i i didn't believe that returns was
the actual problem so i went
to uh krispy kreme um and the krispy
came in toronto
it's like in a really obscure uh
location so like everyone knows the
brand
but no one actually knows where the uh
krispy kreme
actually is so i bought like four boxes
of krispy kreme i took it to a random
co-working space
and people started swarming me asking me
for donuts and i said sure
if you tell me your returns experience
or your online shopping experience and
then every single person pointed towards
returns
and then i realized okay so the idea
earlier was like if
this item was at in my city at the point
that i'd ordered it it'd probably come a
lot faster and a lot cheaper
and then with returns if somehow we can
be able to take that core idea of hyper
localization being the key to reducing
lag and apply it to returns we might get
somewhere
meaning that right now with online
returns specifically if you want to
return something you have to ship it all
the way to the retailer
and right right in australia or in
england and pay shipping fees on top of
that before there's a circle back when
you get your refund about a month or two
later
um what we've realized is that a product
doesn't actually have to leave the
market that it's in
before the consumer which is you and i
can find out if they can get their
refund back
yes or no right um that can all be done
in house and then taking it further we
realized oh wait
so we have this whole solution why not
apply this to both like all kinds of
returns
both um physical returns like some brick
and mortar stores like a walmart or
a target because no one likes going to
the store no one likes waiting online no
one likes those awkward experiences of
having to explain like why am i
returning this item
because it's not right um so we realized
okay we can have this happen for
everyone
and how do we make this possible through
smart boxes we created these smart boxes
um for uh drop-offs of these returns so
basically
how this works is that as a consumer you
can just walk up to this box it's kind
of like an atm
you put it you put your return into the
box and you just walk away
and that entire experience is less than
three minutes it is
totally contact free so you're not
talking to any humans and
especially in light of covid it's
totally like easy
super super short um time period so as
opposed to the almost an hour that you
spend
uh driving to the store waiting in line
and wasting so much time it's just now
reduced into that three-minute time
frame
and it's a really quick turnaround you
just have to wait under 24 hours
and we're hoping to in the next few
years really great partnerships
get it to be instant refunds and that's
uh i think i think that's
a i think that's really really exciting
and i i definitely
the instant refunds is something that it
could be
that you know that i'm definitely seeing
obviously now that everything is
connected
it really the refund is is you just need
a form of proof that you return it then
you can
the the company would probably feel
comfortable issuing that refund and i'm
seeing that there's a few interesting
challenges that i'd love to dive deeper
and get your
pick your brain on first of all you
mentioned this hyperlocalization so
really the problem is that
you want it to be really local to the
person right you don't want them to be
driving
you know and going for that hour back
and forth trip to the post office and
standing in line and do it it needs to
be
one solution for the automation is to
have it as a standalone box you don't
have to communicate with anybody there's
no line
but the other problem is that you need
to be hyper localized so you're dealing
with a problem
where you have to install these things
at scale right how do you how do you
even
go to you know it's like a marketplace
you really need to conquer a city
you really need to have it everywhere so
how do you even go about doing that
for sure i think that um as a company
um again nothing beats experience so one
of the things that we did when we
realized okay we're city by city model
meaning that
we conquer austin right and then we
conquer toronto then we conquer new york
um it was like one of the smartest
people that have ever created
the the biggest and the most important
city by city startup to join our
advisory board
and those two people were very very very
early at uber so one of them currently
manages uber's global operations and
then the other person
was like employee number three or so at
uber so meaning that
they understand how to be able to scale
a company from like the itty bitty
stages
um up until a multi-billion dollar um
you know
franchise and the way that we see things
is that
uh the more so what we do is that we
partner with property management groups
like heinz graystar
companies like hilton and maron and
everything to be able to provide
our arm units which is what our boxes
are
that stands for automated returns
machine and we
partner with them to be able to provide
that inside of their building so once
they have one of these units installed
what happens is that customers are
living in their building can return
the items into that box and then
customers that are in that vicinity or
in that city
can also return or drop off their items
at that box if they're nearby
and the reason why this is so important
is because
especially with regards to the point of
hyper localization
uh our company we're gonna have a bigger
returns footprint than any other store
any other retailer in the world
um and what we can say is that we're
gonna have a bigger returns footprint
than walmart walmart currently has 4 800
uh stores in north america and for us
um there's over 2.3 million uh apartment
buildings and multi-family buildings
that we could potentially put our box in
um if we only hit like 10 of the market
we're bigger than every other
company combined um our goal is to be
able to create a jetsons like future i
don't remember the cartoon the jetsons
where everything just happened
uh you never have to leave your house to
be able to go to a restaurant your house
would become the restaurant and you've
seen that with companies
you never had to go to the mall the mall
would just come to you and for us
it's that reverse experience of bringing
them all back
to the mall so the vision is that you
might be coming home from target and you
realize oh shoot i really should have
bought this journal or maybe i bought
the wrong size as opposed to you having
to waste
fuel and um even like your carbon
footprint and everything
driving back to the target or even
scheduling your entire life
around that return you just drop it off
in that box nearby
or drop it off in the box and you're
going on your way up so that's the kind
of future that we're trying to create
and so you you have that the one piece
of the puzzle is
you as the consumer having to go and
making it you know seamless for me to
return an item then there is a whole
other piece of how do you actually get
that item
uh you know in the same you know
shipping condition to
the to the merchant that you've
partnered with and i'm imagining you
know that
one one arm unit could be suitable with
walmart with target
with you know whatever whatever clothing
store that i just
and you know bloomingdale's or macy's so
how does that
what is sort of the logistic thinking
process behind that
for sure um to be quite frank with you
it's magic
um everything is just magical um but
like yeah there is a logistics network
powering everything and making sure that
things
you know happen and operate smoothly um
on the high level with regards to how
our boxes operate all of our boxes
are compatible with all of the stores
that we're pre
that we're partnered with and that we're
compatible with so for example
um a box won't just do only walmart
returns you'll see on the unit like what
kinds of rich
what stores are available at this
particular place um
it's a city by city variant meaning that
certain cities may have certain stores
that are not available in certain
markets so for example
if you're in new york you might have
like a stacks on your
arm and you're in your building but then
if you're in houston you might have a
ross
or you might have a marshalls and so
like the stores are
for the most part we're um cities city
specific for like more niche
uh retailers right no that makes a lot
of sense and so
one of the things that i'm that i'm
really excited about you know this show
is i get to speak with entrepreneurs
at all different stages of their
companies from very early stage
all the way to to managing public
companies and really picking their brain
on
some of the most you know you know scary
challenging
yet fun and exhilarating things of where
they are today so i'd love to hear from
you
at what stage really would you
categorize at flendel right now and
what are some of them and about the
scariest but also most exhilarating
things that you're
experiencing as a as an early stage
entrepreneur
for sure stage that we would categorize
ourselves
we're at the stage um we're about to
blow up like that's the stage that we're
in so we're just preparing for
takeoff um in terms of what the scariest
things right now
is being able to deal with the increased
demand that has happened in light of
kovitz so
um all of a sudden everybody wants one
of these smart boxes in their buildings
everyone wants to be able to have them
in their senior homes in their
retirement homes
right um i can't go to the store all the
time and that's not safe
and um higher um and uh property
management groups want to incorporate
this to show their tenants that they're
making an effort towards covet
um so for us it's just being able to
deal with the demand and have stellar
customer service while doing so
in terms of the most exciting things
honestly it's just um
we recently that sounded pretty exciting
for me i have to say
what he just said yeah i mean from my
perspective you know
millennials so like the things that
excite me yes i love the fact that we're
increasing our customers and everything
i'm also really excited about the
commercials
so um basically we're really really
excited about the fact
that um we have a lot of really great
announcements coming up
including new advisory board members
that um
are like super super advantageous to the
company and towards fueling our mission
um the other thing is just that in terms
of the things that you know are tough to
handle right now is just the increased
demand like i mentioned before everyone
wants an er unboxing they're building
now
from uh your retirement homes and
seniors that can't afford to
you know risk their lives to go drop
return a stock at the local walmart at
the local target
to higher end property manager groups
that are looking to offer this amenity
towards showing their customers and
their tenants that
they are making an increased effort
towards being able to protect the safety
and everything in light of the
condemning so we're really excited about
the future
and super bullish on us long term
right how do you see you know the
landscape of companies that are working
on this obviously you know where we can
look at companies like amazon that are
working
extremely hard on their fulfillment
process and return process whether it
may be through
you know a drone deliveries or whether
it be you know the requisitions of
multiple you know last mile companies
obviously i'm saying the other you know
the everybody else really
that doesn't have the capacity to to run
these massive operations
that they are you know excited to
utilize these resources because they
don't want to be dealing with you know
returns
hyper localized returns all over the
united states so are there
other really big people that are trying
to tackle this problem what's been
the response that you are getting from
these retailers and companies that that
are potential partners of yours
for sure i mean from a retailer
perspective um you have to remember that
infrastructure is a very difficult thing
to be able to
do right so what these companies end up
doing even companies
on the largest scale like walmart and
everything they end up relying on other
um parties towards being able to
complement those existing services
so for example uh with us like we're not
in competition with amazon we're more of
a compliment to companies like amazon
so we are a totally different market
segment totally different customer
segment and eventually we will be able
to do
um returns with amazon in partnership so
like for us it's not like a
the return space is a very fragmented
space it's also a very massive
opportunity it's still quite early um
with regards to now companies are now
starting to pay attention to returns
uh before uh companies like amazon set a
president
in terms of uh super fast fulfillment
super fast delivery get this thing today
right now i'm thinking about how can we
get this item back to the consumer and
how can we
you know optimize on the consumer's
experience so they keep coming back so
our company
um is only going to help to accelerate
that and again we have the advantage of
being just super super super early into
the space
yeah right now and i i have to say that
you know i'm i'm excited to go on my own
venture
soon rather than later and i'm excited
to get as excited as you are
talking about the different things that
are happening yeah it sounds
it sounds really really wonderful well
go to tell me a little bit about what
surprised you as an early stage founder
along along this process you're growing
very fast you're seeing
a surge of demand for your product
you're you're you know you're bringing
people on board you have
an engineering team in toronto while you
know uh
some other folks are in austin so you're
traveling back and forth
what what is it what is the experience
like what has been some of the most
surprising things that perhaps
a fresh young entrepreneur starting
their journey wouldn't even think of
um very random but i
don't don't wear a suit to meetings i
remember my very first meeting
and i remember like just thinking of
what i thought the
um startup world would be like and how
it's supposed to be business these are
people that are conducting multi-million
deals and everything and
a friend of mine um that had introduced
me to an investor for practice right and
this was before flinto was even flint
this is when i decided that i was going
to
you know like be in this space and i
went to the meeting had a suit on
i looked like i was going to review on
wall street and the meeting he messaged
me that this was almost
at starbucks and i said okay i think
he's asking to meet at the starbucks so
he can leave me to his office because
obviously he doesn't want to meet right
at his office
and the meeting was at starbucks so i
get to the starbucks i sit down i'm
waiting on this dude he comes in like a
t-shirt
right and this is a dude that like sold
over six companies
um for nine figures like i i came in and
i'm like huh
and then he looks at me and he looks
confused and i'm like i'm coming back
from a function that's what i said
um because i was so embarrassed and
everything that could have possibly
um went wrong in that meeting happened
but
amazing good thing it was a practice
yeah it was a really great thing for me
because at the end and i haven't spoken
to that person since
but um at the end of the day what it did
to
me that you shouldn't take yourself too
seriously number one number two um you
shouldn't be afraid to fail
um like there's so many different things
like as long as required is okay it's
okay to continue pivoting and it's okay
to continue adapting and adjusting so
you shouldn't be married to
the entire thing you should be married
to the core concept things change over
time
and the other thing is just like again
like don't wear a suit to a meeting
because the suit means opposite it means
you're trying too hard
um versus i've gotten more respect than
t-shirt and jeans i don't have
wearing any dressed up attire so that's
one of the things that i love most about
this space
i i completely love that a few words
about you know deciding to
uh launch the company in austin with
engineering in toronto
you know i i just recently spoke with a
good friend of mine who's a principal
at the at a big vc in early stage vc
based in in texas but tell me a little
bit about your decision to start the
company there obviously i know you grew
up
in the area but did you was there a
decision to be made or was it natural
that it was that it would be yeah
so i um i i did grow up in houston which
is about a two-hour drive from austin
and um the thing with toronto
is that toronto is a really interesting
city so toronto is great
for uh like the up and coming
entrepreneurs that are in toronto like
from a labor perspective
um as an american looking in um
there's a lot of benefits um towards
having a certain amount of staff
located in toronto and operating in
toronto in terms of austin i mean austin
is
texas so texas i'm naturally bound for
it
um and i'll argue night and day that
it's way better than the bay area and
you know this by virtue of all of the
people that are now moving down to
austin and you know
but um austin has a lot of really great
things the city is full of so much life
and
has so much character and then the tech
ecosystem there is like booming
at an incredible rate i was taking an
uber and the uber driver like pitched me
and then we connected and that was like
that kind of atmosphere that kind of
ecosystem i love that
only fine in the bay area now you're
finding it in other markets and other
cities
uh plus the weather is great so i'm not
going to complain
and it's a problem free state so we're
going to be thankful for that so
yeah there's just so many different and
great um benefits like both from a
personal perspective and then also from
an economical perspective as to why
you know texas specifically also just
like the rights for
any company really to be able to grow
and thrive in
i love it ugochi thank you so much for
taking the time to be here i really
really appreciate it before we leave i
have to ask you for the most important
question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
um funny witty
and charismatic i love that ugochi oh
thank you so much for being here
and best of luck with flendel i i can't
wait to see it
for myself i can't wait to use it myself
and i can't wait to see where you take
this journey
forward so thank you for coming thank
you so much it was great to be here